- Welcome back to you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much.
I brought the whole team.
- And welcome.
I know, and welcome to the show, guys.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Thank you.
- I'm a huge fan of all three of you.
Okay, so do you,
did you know Matt and
Ben before this show?
- No. I didn't.
- [Kelly] (indistinct)
We met a few times and
and we had one cool time we met.
- By we met, you mean I
constantly would run into you
and be like, Chris, I wanna
be in a movie with you.
And you were like, nice to see you.
(audience laughing)
- He was so kind.
He was so kind always.
He said, we, you're a genius.
I wanna' work with you.
I thought he was just
Hollywood or something,
you know, playing around, but-
- Well, I am.
- he was serious.
So it was cool.
But one time we met at a like bathroom
you know, we was...
- We don't talk about that.
(everyone laughing)
- You don't wanna, yeah,
you don't talk about,
okay, well, that's the first time we met.
And all of us,
but we've met at award
shows and stuff like that.
And it was a lot of fun
meeting over the years.
- I've been trying.
I mean, I think he's so brilliant.
And when I-
- [Kelly] I agree.
- found out about this role,
I was just like maybe I can
finally get Chris Tucker
to do a movie with me.
(audience tittering)
- [Kelly] Yeah
- Yeah, yeah.
- Dreams happen.
They come true.
- It did come true.
It did, yes.
- Yes.
So is it true that you recently said
that Chris is who you
wanna be when you grow up?
(Kelly and guests laughing)
- I didn't say it in front of him.
You're embarrassing me now.
(everyone laughing)
Yeah, man.
Chris is a great guy with a real integrity
and he's brilliant and he's a great dad
and he's just a and
also, he knows everybody.
(Chris and Matt laughing)
Like, I'm not even kidding,
you can bring up a name,
it doesn't matter if
it's like Muhammad Ali,
Paul McCartney, Jesus, you know,
Chris is like, yeah, that's my boy.
(everyone laughing)
I'm like, what do you
mean that's your boy?
How do you know?
Like, not only do you know Michael Jordan.
I was like, there's this guy Howard White
who works at-, he goes,
I know Howard White, he's my friend.
I'm like, this is an unbelievable-
- Oh my gosh, your his guy.
- [Ben] I still have not
found anyone you don't know.
- You know everybody?
- I kinda' do, you know.
(everyone laughing)
and I mean, Ben and my
buddy Dave Chappelle,
they always joke like,
you know everybody, man,
you everywhere.
Where are you right now?
I'm like, I'm in Saudi
Arabia with the king.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- I'll call you right back.
He's giving gifts away.
(audience laughing)
- He's giving gifts away.
- It's his Oprah's favorite things.
(indistinct). That's amazing.
- [Chris] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay. How about like Stevie Wonder?
You know Stevie Wonder?
- I know Stevie.
Stevie's, aw man, he called me.
- Keep trying.
(Chris laughing)
You're gonna' have to go way
deeper than Stevie Wonder.
- I thought I was gonna be cool
'cause he handed me my first Grammy.
So I was gonna be like, my
story is pretty good, Chris.
- [Matt] Oh.
- [Chris] Oh man, oh yeah.
- No, but you know Stevie though.
- I was like, you know
Muhammad Ali is one-
he was like, yeah, I met
Muhammad, I love Muhammad Ali.
- I met Muhammad Ali.
- Muhammad Ali.
- He said, you a funny mother Tucker.
I said, oh, (indistinct)
- Oh, did he?
(everyone laughing)
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah, I thought he
was gonna say something else,
you know.
- I'm like that's some (indistinct)
- [Chris] Like some (indistinct),
- [Ben] (indistinct)
- you know.
- right there.
- (indistinct) mother Tucker.
- You should've retired.
That's as good as it's gonna' get.
- I know. (laughing)
- Muhammad Ali.
- Met Mandela, met Mandela.
- Oh my God.
- Went to Africa and he was like,
where is Chris Tucker?
(everyone laughing)
I want him to meet my grandkids.
(audience laughing)
I was like, did Mandela
just say my name?
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- BB King. BB King.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- [Matt] Oh wow.
- He was like, hey, Chris.
Yep, Bill Russell.
People like that.
I mean it's great to,
you know, just meet them.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- Now you know, I wanna' be Chris Tucker.
(everyone laughing)
- Are you the person
that can really remember?
Like, I was a waitress
so I feel like I'm really good with faces,
but names I'm always like interesting.
- Yes, I, faces but not names.
Yeah. You use the right,
you must be left-handed.
You use the right side of your brain.
- No, I'm, no, I'm right-handed.
- [Chris] Oh okay.
- But like, I have horrible handwriting
so it doesn't matter which hand I'm using-
- Me too. Me too.
- Yes.
But no, I literally,
I can remember faces well,
but names I'm always like,
you.
- Oh yeah, yeah,
you do (indistinct) faces.
- You do the,
nice to see ya'.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah
- Especially, if it's outta' context.
- [Ben] Yeah, yeah.
- Well, last time Ben was here,
he told us something that you
guys did back in the day that,
I'm just gonna actually roll a tape.
Let's just see it.
- [Matt] What?
- Matt Damon, we had
some nylon Puma suits-
- [Kelly] (laughing) Oh my god.
- and Nike suits.
In those days, you know,
then, the tracksuits,
they're like nice though.
Then they were just one thin like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- nylon sheet, you know?
- But that was cool. And-
(Kelly laughing)
we wore them and we, you know,
that was what was going on
and we wanted to be cool
and so we learned how to break dance.
And then Matt was like, if
we just get some linoleum
and put it down at the subway,
we could do some of our mov- you know,
and like put out a hat.
Matt tried to do the windmill,
which he never quite mastered.
I could get the back
spin and the kick worm,
although I never,
if you asked me to do that now,
you'd end up with a lawsuit
because I'd cripple myself immediately.
- [Kelly] (laughing) You're (indistinct)
Yes.
Yeah, horrendous.
(audience applauding)
- Who was the worst?
- Well, I mean that's
sort of like, you know,
the small, world's smallest ant, you know,
it's a certain place, not really re-
- (laughing) It's not relevant?
- You know these two like-
an eight and a 10-year-old white kid
rolling up a thing of
linoleum on the subway,
putting a hat down.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Wearing like nylon suits
going like, you know,
I mean it was-
- [Kelly] Check this out.
- mortifying.
Yeah. It was really-
- We realized pretty quickly
we were gonna have to find
another way to make money.
(everyone laughing)
- You were like, so check, not this.
- The subway guy was charging
- [Matt] Yeah.
- us to be down there.
(Chris laughing)
- Did you ever do anything like
that when you were younger?
Like a (indistinct)
- You know, I tried.
The only thing I could
do was the centipede,
the worm thing after that.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- That was-
- The thing everybody could do?
- Don't say that. Not
everybody could do that.
- No, that's when you're a kid,
you're flexible like that.
Matt tried to do the
windmill, but never quite got-
- I never could do it.
- What's the windmill?
- [Ben] The windmill?
You're young.
- When you go up on your shoulders.
- Oh no, no, no.
I know what that is.
I didn't know the name of it.
Okay. I know what that is.
- Yeah, the windmill.
I could never-
- You probably can do the-
you probably know the guy
who invented the windmill.
- Hey, man, please.
Oh please.
- All I'm thinking
about is a chiropractor.
Okay.
(audience applauding)
- We are here the stars
of the new movie Air,
which is in theater starting April 5th.
First of all,
congratulations, Ben, on Air.
It is an incredible story.
And it's interesting,
I knew nothing about
Michael Jordan's start,
I knew nothing about the company.
I knew nothing.
And it is so informative
and funny and serious
and has real issues that you talk about-
- Yeah.
- as far as knowing your works.
- Well, that's interesting
'cause there are people
who like definitely
are kind of not into sports
or basketball sports,
- That's not me, yeah.
- Movies, or that kind
of thing who are like,
oh see, that's not my thing.
But actually it's not that, it's really,
there's not a, it's not a rah-rah thing.
It's not about like you
have to know the sport
and the locker room
and we're gonna win it.
It's about how this person, you know,
Michael Jordan meant so much to the world
and represented something
so big and so amazing.
He kind of changed the way
the world perceived athletes
and the way they connected
a Nike in concert with him.
Kind of,
it was the first time you
associated a product, a brand-
- Yeah.
- with a person and their identity.
Back then they were in the
cellar with basketball shoes.
Converse was killing,
Adidas was the cool shoes.
- I didn't know all that.
- [Matt And Ben] Yeah.
- I know.
- And Nike cooled it up.
- That was the weird thing,
reading the script was,
I mean I just thought it
was such a great story
that I didn't know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we kind of, at the
beginning of the movie
did have to re contextualize
that time because you go,
we all live in the world
post-Michael Jordan,
post-Air Jordan.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
So to take us back to that time
right before it all happened
and what the world looked like.
And it's funny to think
of Nike as an underdog
'cause they're, so-
- That's what I'm saying.
- Everywhere.
- And then knowing
Adidas, like it was just,
it was an interesting thing
that I did not know about.
Even how I loved when you
and Viola Davis's character
were at her house and you were just going
back and forth about like what
to expect in those meetings.
- Right, right.
- And they like play it out, like,
it was brilliant and it was funny,
but it was really honest as well.
And it really showed how the
company really got behind him
and y'all literally sank
everything into like,
they sanked everything
into this one person.
- Well, it seems like a,
like an obvious thing now,
- [Kelly] But not then.
- But it was a massive gamble
that they (indistinct).
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- What I loved about it
is, as you mentioned Viola,
is that you think it's really,
well, it's gonna be this guy Sunny's Story
or it's gonna be Michael Jordan's story,
and you get halfway through the movie,
which sort of mirrored the
process I had in exploring it
and trying to put it put together the cast
and the whole sort of ideas
that were important to me.
And you find out really
like, I almost like,
I was almost embarrassed that it didn't,
wasn't obviously to begin with.
That without Dolores Jordan, his mother,
- Yeah.
- Really guiding him and helping him-
- None of that would've happened.
- and making us do-
none of that would happen.
(Chris and Matt murmuring)
And it just makes so much sense.
Like all these moms, like
I think of my own mom.
My mom loves all my movies,
you know what I mean?
She thinks everything's great.
I'm like, they're not all great mom.
(everyone laughing)
But you know, God loves her and your mom,
nobody loves you like your mother.
And the way that especially young people
and the case of the NBA and entertainment,
you see, they get thrust
into these positions,
sometimes they're from
marginalized communities.
They've historically
been taken advantage of.
And here they're with these opportunities,
they're supposed to be negotiating
with these massive companies.
It's a whole, you know,
we know a little bit
about sort of stepping
from one world into another.
It's a lot.
And if you don't have that
person there to anchor you
and guide you, you might be in trouble.
- And also though, what you're saying,
it seems a bit normalized now.
People do fight for
that now, but back then,
like even on the phone
call, you were like,
oh ma'am, you don't know how this works-
- Right.
- And she was basically like,
but this is how it's going to
- [Chris, Matt, And Ben] Yeah.
- if you'd like to work with my-
and I thought that was so powerful.
(audience applauding)
- Because it's important to understand,
the people that said no,
there's a difference
between a salary and a fee
and ownership.
- Yeah.
- (indistinct) people,
owners, in other words,
you go out and you create
the value in the shoe
by being Michael Jordan.
Well, you are an owner of your identity
and you should own what
that means to this company.
It's not like, yeah, well
we get to pay your fee
and oh, good for us.
We make billions of dollars
and you make your fee.
- Yeah.
I will say one of my favorite parts too,
and I think that this gets lost sometimes.
Everybody knows at this point
Michael Jordan is Michael Jordan.
He is the greatest. Right?
So like, everybody knows that.
So, but the the point is, is that
everybody doesn't know the
people behind the scenes
that made that whole brand,
that made all of that
Nike, everything come play.
- By the way, Michael
Jordan's not in the movie.
- That's powerful. Yeah.
- On purpose because I-
- I love that by the way.
- If you just show somebody,
- You never really see
- you try to pretend-
- Yeah.
- and tell them this is Michael Jordan,
because he is so iconic and means so much,
immediately,
- I thought that was
brilliant.
- you know, it's a lie.
Immediately the movie falls apart.
- Yeah.
- And what's more interesting
is that the way our heroes,
these gods kind of operate in our lives
is not in our day-to-day
lives, but we see them,
you see him on footage in game films.
- Yeah.
- But you know, they're not in real life.
They're larger than life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you, the audience
brings their imagination
and memory to it.
And it's, you know, I do really think
it's my favorite movie I've ever made.
Viola Davis is amazing.
Julius Tennon--
- Yeah.
- I mean Jason Bateman, Chris Tucker.
- The cast is incredible.
Yeah.
- These are brilliant,
they did a great job.
I just watched.
I'm so proud of it.
It really is fun.
- [Kelly] The writing is incredible.
- It really should be seen in the theater.
It's a lot of fun in the theater.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- April 5th, check it out.
- It's so good.
I literally have told everyone.
I literally went to a show,
I did this show last night
and I walked in and like,
now my eyes go to Jordan's.
And so I'm like, and I
walked in, I was like,
oh my God you're gonna love the movie.
I was like, I was, I'm
like you're street team.
(everyone laughing)
I'm like, everywhere I go, like literally.
And then I had conversations
with everybody about this movie
and I'm like, they're like,
okay, should I see it?
And I was like, you should 100% see it.
- [Matt] Yup.
- I was like, it's so good.
- This is the beginning of shoe culture.
- I know.
- This is the very first time.
- That's a whole thing too.
Yeah. It like, it ignited this whole-
I, my closet is mainly sneakers.
Like my, like I love it.
Like I think a lot of us are like that.
- Mm-hmm. Yup.
- [Kelly] And boots.